scott pilgrim vs the world is a decade
old and this ode to the aimlessness of
young adulthood still has a cult
following but while the film is
whimsical it also has its flaws here are
aspects of the film that take on new
meaning for adults
the very first line of the movie informs
us that 22 year old scott pilgrim is
dating a high schooler the 17 year old
knives chow how old are you now scott
like 28 even though the audience
subsequently learns that they haven't
even kissed yet it's still icky and only
gets worse as you get further and
further from high school yourself
you're too good for him
run
some of scott's friends to their credit
point out that scott is hiding in a safe
pressure-free non-relationship in the
wake of a bad breakup the previous year
others however are completely fine with
the idea as knives begins to attend
scott's band practice and shows his
roommate wallace for some reason agrees
to wait outside knives school with scott
until the final bell rings at the film's
end ramona even hints that scott and
knives should get back together
what you two make a good combo
in fact the ending originally shot for
the film had scott and knives getting
back together when that divided test
audiences it was revised to scott and
ramona starting over instead but
speaking with collider in 2021 edgar
wright the film's director explained
that even in making that adjustment the
key to it was that knives lets him go
[Music]
i'm too cool for you anyway
so even now the one-sided relationship
that many would say has all the
hallmarks of an adult man grooming a
teenager is considered a legitimate side
of a love triangle as the years go by
that part of the movie gets harder to
defend
in a 2007 essay for the av club about
the movie elizabeth town pop culture
critic nathan raven coined a new phrase
saying the manic pixie dream girl exists
solely in the fevered imaginations of
sensitive writer directors to teach
broodingly soulful young men to embrace
life and its infinite mysteries and
adventures within a few years it became
a widely used term to describe the many
movies where a colorful lively young
woman like kate winslet in eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind or natalie
portman in garden state lures a mopey
male protagonist out of his shell
i make a noise or i do something that no
one has ever done before and then i can
feel unique again even if it's only for
like a second
it's intriguing to consider in
retrospect whether ramona flowers
conforms to this trope while she's a
more detached quiet character than your
bubbly zoe deschanel types she
unfortunately fits all the other
stereotypes she never appears in the
movie on her own what glimpses we do get
of her life are only in regards to her
past relationships and the movie never
explains what drew her to scott in the
first place so in place of personality
and character the audience gets a female
lead who has lots of exes and colorful
hair along with a montage of people at a
party telling scott cryptic things about
ramona she's got some battle scars dude
there is a relatively fun self-aware gag
in the movie about ramona appearing in
scott's dreams via a convenient subspace
highway which is how she becomes the
girl of his dreams but although mary
elizabeth winstead brings admirable
depth to the role with her performance
as the years go by it becomes harder not
to wish there was more of a sense of who
ramona is when she's not simply
servicing scott's story
the way the lgbtq characters are
presented in pilgrim might set off
different reactions in focus groups
today than it did a decade ago wallis
wells scott's gay roommate has an active
seemingly polyamorous lifestyle which is
fine even scott doesn't mind it despite
sharing the same bed
hey morning hey jimmy double standard
but it seems like wallace can't have a
single conversation without asking if
boys go to knife school or pretending
that the girl scott is referring to is a
boy from stealing scott's sister's
boyfriend during a concert to watching
lucas lee film a movie because he's his
crush it really is bizarre how every
opportunity wallace has to speak turns
into an opportunity to reinforce his
sexual identity kieron culkin's
performance makes wallace consistently
amusing but revisit the movie again and
you'll be amazed at how one note the
character feels roxy richter meanwhile
is all but ridiculed as a phase by
ramona when she is revealed to be her
fourth evil ex given no backstory or
flashback other than ramona saying she
was once by curious roxy seems to exist
just to make some lesbian related puns
well honey
i'm a little five
another strange aspect of scott pilgrim
versus the world you might notice as you
get older and more worldly is its
off-kilter relationship with non-white
characters matthew patel the first of
ramona's evil exes is of indian canadian
heritage a fact that isn't terribly
relevant until he launches into a
bollywood dance number near the end of
his fight with scott the fifth and sixth
evil exes the kata yanagi twins fall
into the silent asian stereotype that
was once called out last year by mulan
actor jimmy wong even knives while she
gets plenty of lines and time to shine
as a character beyond her ethnicity is
referred to in a strange loaded moment
as scott is talking to his friends
knives ciao
she's chinese
we're kid it's a small moment but it
plays into the larger trope of
fetishizing asian female characters one
that has come under fire in the years
since the film's release
scott pilgrim is unemployed he's also 22
and dating a high schooler in a strange
sexless pretend relationship he shares a
studio apartment with another man who
owns all of the furniture and the lone
bed this studio apartment is across the
street from the house where scott grew
up other than perhaps playing bass in an
unheralded band there isn't much about
scott pilgrim that doesn't scream loser
scott spends nearly the entirety of the
film's run time acting whiny insecure
selfish he cheats on his high school
girlfriend then dumps her without
explanation he makes the barest attempts
at apologies and introspection right
before the film is over but it's clear
he hasn't grown much by the movie's
conclusion
hey
hey
mind if i tag along
if they were to make a sequel we'd most
likely discover 10 years later that
scott is still not nearly as cool as the
original film frequently made him seem
chris evans has appeared as captain
america in the marvel universe in 11
different movies it's hard not to
imagine what comedic roles he turned
down to spend a decade in spandex after
re-watching his uproarious turn as lucas
lee and scott pilgrim vs the world
beginning with the moment he cracks his
neck in time with the universal
picture's fanfare evans generates the
most consistent laughs per minute of any
of the evil exes or perhaps any
character in the film playing an
absurdly aggro movie star in a bit of
self-parody after his two movie turns as
a pre-mcu human torch in the fox
fantastic four movies evans has perfect
timing in declaring that scott pilgrim
is no competition and throwing him into
toronto's iconic casa loma
hi
big fan
why wouldn't you be with captain america
now behind him evan's sly turn in knives
out is hopefully just the tip of more
interesting diverse roles to come
beyond whether she qualifies as a manic
pixie dream girl cliche or not romana
flowers has a frustrating lack of agency
in scott pilgrim vs the world this feels
all the more grating when you grow up
and realize how complicated a good love
story can be in movies disciplined
enough to properly develop one it's
entirely unexplained why ramona invites
scott back to her place and makes out
with him on a date that was explicitly
pitched as a platonic hangar while the
revelation of the league of evil exes
complicates her story and explains some
of her detached attitude it's not
terribly clear how the league haunting
her makes her feel other than as it
pertains to scott when she abruptly
leaves scott to return to her ex gideon
it's a bummer but at least a decisive
action that hints at deeper motivations
but even that turns out to be telling
someone else's story as gideon has
attached a mind control device to the
back of her head transforming her
entirely into a damsel in distress for
the film's big action climax adding
insult to injury she mostly takes a back
seat in the showdown with gideon as
scott and knives do most of the fighting
scott pilgrim vs the world was
celebrated upon its release for having
an array of diverse female roles but in
actuality it fails the standard bearer
test of representation in cinema known
as the bechdel test named for cartoonist
alison bechdel it goes like this to pass
the test a film must have at least two
female characters that talk to one
another about something other than a man
revisiting scott pilgrim versus the
world it never quite passes even when
ramona knives envy or others make small
talk with another female character it's
always about scott gideon or some other
mutual male friend or ex-boyfriend the
bechdel test sounds so simple give your
character enough depth to say something
other than a line that advances the male
antagonist story but in films like
pilgrim it is apparently impossible to
imagine these female characters having
their own distinct lives
as adults it's easy to be hard on an
unemployed loser like scott pilgrim as
it's a coming-of-age story you might say
he's supposed to be a loser in the
beginning surely he grows and changes
over the course of the film in a word
no
scott spends the majority of the film as
a self-centered entitled whiny and
defensive character when he reluctantly
admits to knives and ramona that he
cheated on both of them he at last has
an opportunity to act mature but gideon
stabs him in the back killing him in a
video game twist an extra life that
scott earned earlier allows him to come
back and replay the final fight again
this time he gets a brief monologue
where he reveals to knives and ramona
that he cheated on them voluntarily but
still doesn't have to deal with any
significant consequences
so are we all good
[Music]
never felt better in this final sequence
the first time through he fights gideon
with a sword he earned through the power
of love but on the second pass he earns
it through the power of self-respect
this makes no sense because scott has
demonstrated that if anything he has too
much self-respect is there a sword you
earn by respecting the women in your
life because scott needs to earn that
one
scott pilgrim vs the world is largely a
video game inspired fantasy so maybe
it's not fair to hold it to a coherent
standard in terms of today's gender
politics but the older you get the more
you start to realize that the league of
evil x's is more than just a framework
to structure the story around it's toxic
masculinity in its purest form without
much nuance or backstory the fighting in
the movie reduces dating to a tournament
where ramona is the prize objectifying
women as objects to be fought over
instead of human beings with willpower
thoughts and feelings while this is
partially the result of distilling a
six-volume graphic novel into a two-hour
film it ultimately creates something
that's fun and flashy but reduces gender
rules to a digital binary men are stoic
warriors while women are princesses and
towers to be claimed as rewards
with the exception of michael cera
virtually every member of the cast of
scott pilgrim vs the world was more or
less on the rise and has seen their
careers blossom in the years since
looking back now you see aubry plaza
before parks and recreation chris evans
and brie larson before the mcu got them
anna kendrick before up in the air and
pitch perfect and the list goes on but
when the film hit theaters in 2010 the
consensus seemed to be that ellen wong
had stolen the show as knives chow and
seemed poised to be the film's breakout
in the years since wang has worked
steadily playing a semi-prominent
supporting role on netflix's glow for
three years before its cancellation yet
the ellen wong mania that seemed about
to materialize a decade ago never quite
went down as planned looking back now as
an adult perhaps it's time to once again
appreciate her performance and seek out
some of the smaller goals she's capably
filmed in the years since
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]